الساعه الان في ايران حسب توقيت الشعب
الايراني الغاضب الذي استجاب الى دعوات
الاضراب العام فاغلقت المحلات في سائر
انحاء البلاد وخرج العديد من الايرانيين
لتوفيق هذه اللحظات
مقاطع عديده انتشرت عبر شبكات التواصل
الاجتماعي
من المجتمع بالاضراب مديره المخابرات
الامريكيه افريل هايينز قالت ان النظام
ايران لا يشعر بتهديد مشاكل الان لكن
اضراب الاسواق في ايران سيؤدي الى عدم
استقراره لانه سيؤدي في النهايه الى زياده
مخاطر الاضطرابات
الاضراب لقي دعما من الفنانين والرياضيين
الذين اعلنوا انهم سيوقفون انشطتهم خلال
الايام الثلاثه
كما ان الطلاب الجامعيين
ملتزمون بالاضراب لانهم اساسا من اطلقوه
مع بدايه الاحتجاجات
وخرج عمال مصنع الاسمنت في اصفهان للتعبير
عن سخطهم فيما اعلن مئات العمال في مجال
النفط اضرابهم وتاتي الاضرابات الواسعه
النطاق داخل ايران في وقت يتزايد فيه
الضغط على النظام الايراني في الخارج
انس نماسي العربيه